hello everybody
welcome to the third day of our bootcamp
uh today in the morning we have we have
antam gupta to give talks about
competitive analysis of my algorithms
so i am connie wong from i just
graduated from duke university i'm a
research pharmacy and you probably have
already known anupam he's a professor of
computer science from carnegie mellon
university
and he mostly works in theoretical
computer science
and we have
thanks cool thanks
and
hopefully you guys can hear me friend
okay and if you can't understand what
i'm writing uh just just speak up
so i'm going to talk about competitive
analysis online algorithms
and this is in contrast to the
the regret uh base analysis that you've
seen in the past few days and so maybe
you know since this is supposed to be a
survey basically what i'm going to do is
i'm going to give you the basics first
so that everybody is on board so some of
you are specialists already and you
might find it a little slow but
hopefully you can you know think of
interesting problems to work on
and interesting extensions of the stuff
that we're talking about and then in the
sort of second half second half of the
talk so this is going to be a two hour
talk in the first hour i'll give you a
couple of problems so you know maybe
here's the thing i'm going to define
the problem then i'm going to give you
two examples and we're going to work
through these in some detail and these
are simple but you know we'll just get
started get the blood flowing and then
in the second half hopefully we'll we'll
start getting into more sort of
techniques
and uh techniques both for algorithms
and for analysis
so uh we'll see how that goes and you
know if things are slow you can ask me
to speed up you know it's supposed to be
very informal so please
speak up if something seems
a mess
so let's start off with uh the setting
the setting is you know we have an
online setting
so online setting at every time
we get uh
let's say request
rt
and we take an action
80
and we
incur a cost
cost of 80
and
what we're going to do is these costs
are going to add up over time and what
we are interested in is what i'll call
alg
on a request sequence and i'll just call
this an instance i i is an instance it's
it's a sequence so i
is going to be r1 r2
rp
and alg i in general you know this might
change sometimes but most of the times
it'll be cost of 80.
so every time i see a request
i handle that request by taking an
action
and already you're seeing the difference
with the sort of
regret based uh settings that we saw
earlier where we were
taking an action and then seeing the
response of the world to it
of course you might say this is just an
off by one thing
but sometimes this changes the way in
which we
analyze these and the kind of results we
can get
so i see a request i take an action
somebody says okay i need a uh you know
i need a page in my cache
i have to have that page in my cache so
i have to take an action i have to evict
some page from my current cache and
bring in a new page into my cache
it's like this okay request action and
this is algorithm and then i'm going to
compare it to what i'll call opt i
which is the
best
sequence
of actions
to serve
so if i could see i up front
i would take
some sequence of actions and this
sequence of actions could change over
time
and this is the cost of the best
sequence of actions so maybe you know
often i'll
use opti to refer to both the sequence
and the cost as well
and i can say the competitive
ratio
of a
is the max
over all instances i
of
i
it's the worst case input
for this algorithm compared to the
optimum so i'm looking at multiplicative
guarantees
so you know i can just
say that if the competitive ratio i'm
saying is alpha this means that alg
i
is at most alpha times
opt i
what i pay is at most alpha times the
optimum solution
so far so good
this alpha is called the competitive
ratio of the algorithm and of course
what are we interested in we are
interested in algorithms which have
small competitive ratio
comparative analysis is just the study
of online algorithms to be that online
because this is uh what's happening is
i'm taking an action without knowledge
of future requests
so it's online
the the quantity i'm looking at is the
comparative ratio
and i'm trying to minimize that
that's pretty much
the model
questions
good
so you know one thing that uh you'll all
you're seeing is firstly you know
there's several differences with the
regret based analysis that we've seen
firstly there is there was this kind of
inversion we see a request and then we
take an action after that
the second thing that we are seeing is
we are allowing ourselves to compare
to the best sequence of actions so this
is like dynamic regret
i'm not sticking to one fixed action in
hindsight and saying how do i compare
based on that
i'm allowing myself to move
and i'm allowing the adversary
the benchmark so very often i'll call
this the benchmark
i'm allowing the benchmark to move
so this is this is very good for
situations where i want to compare
myself to a dynamic optimum
and uh
and in general i'll be looking for
multiplicative guarantees they're
essentially you know additive guarantees
are rare if any
i'm trying to think uh not really
so i'll be looking at multiplicative
guarantees but you know sometimes we'll
see what we can
uh one minor thing that i'm just going
to add in sometimes for problems what
i'll do is i'll allow myself an additive
constant out there
and this constant should not depend upon
any instance so this should be like a
universal constant
it might be you know
you might be given a graph
which is fixed up front
and then requests come over time
the instance is just the sequence of
requests the graph is fixed so this
constant might depend on the size of the
graph let's say
but we'll try to make this as small as
possible if it if it is even there
most of the time you shouldn't worry
about this guy you should just think of
the red stuff
all good
so let's do a couple of prompts uh
this thing and you know it's it's uh
it's almost
conventional to start off with this
problem
and we'll go over this you know
hopefully fast if
so people call this rent or buy
we call it ski rental
it's a nice problem because it just make
sure that you have the uh
the the definitions down in your mind
and you have the issues as well and
you'll see a lot of the issues that will
come in will be issues that we'll see in
more detail later on
so what's uh ranked by you uh
you live in an apartment you can either
buy it
you can rent
for
a dollar a day let's say whatever
it's a theory problem
or you can buy it for b dollars
you don't know how long you're going to
live in this place
so the question is should you rent or
should you buy
what should you do
and what's the information that's coming
in on every day
you know what's the what's rt right on
the 10th day you wake up and you you
you're told oh you're going to stay for
one more day
so now you have to decide should i just
buy it on this day or should i write for
one more day and then wait until
tomorrow
so many of you might have seen this or
if you haven't seen this whatever what's
a good algorithm
should you buy on the first
day no you shouldn't buy on the first
date because
if you bought in the first day what's
your cost b
and look at the instance which just says
yes for one day
you want to you know live in this
apartment only for one day you paid b
the optimal solution for that day was
once
the ratio is b
what's a good answer
somebody anyway come on
when should you buy
after b days so after b days so so
here's the algorithm uh
y
after
b days
right
what's the ratio of this
and really you know let me just do this
very quickly so the algorithm
says you know if
so okay
let me just introduce some notation i
sub j
is the instance
that
uh
where you you know
that says
yes
or
j base
right
so the algorithm says if if you see an
instance
which is less than equal to b
then you'll pay j
because you're not buying
or less than b when you pay j
else
you will pay
2b
minus 1.
if the instance just says yes for one
day if you want to legit there's just
one day you'll pay one
one one one two three four up to b minus
one and on the bs day you'll have paid b
minus one and b more
this is the algorithms cost
what's the optimum cost
i
mean
and essentially you know what's the
worst case input that you can give me
you can give you should give me an
instance which stops
as soon as i buy
this always happens whenever i buy a
book i never read it after that so it's
the same principle right so uh so as
soon as i buy
so really you know in the worst case
i'll pay 2b minus 1 or we'll pay b
that's 2 minus 1 over 2.
and in fact this is the best possible
you can check
that if you bought a little earlier
what will make you pay more
and you know if you bought a little
later why you know you're paying more
than two b minus one opt is still
playing b
so if if the algorithm if the algorithm
was ai
so the the
ai is the algorithm
that pays
that buys
on
day i
if
is
j is less than i than j okay but
except
else
it's i minus one
this is the algorithm
this is the algorithms first if i was
going to buy on day i
if the instance was shorter
i would not buy i would just rant
otherwise i would have bought for i
minus one days and
rented y minus 1 days and then bond
and the minimum still remains the same
on this is on instance
if you're trying to sort of minimize
this in your head right now you know
don't you know
do it later don't worry
actually you'll see another proof just
or at least prove my picture
so far so good
two minus one over b is the optimal
answer for
deterministic algorithms
an algorithm which you know all
deterministic algorithms in this case
look like the following grand try and
try and trend buy
you'll never rank after that because
you've already bought
so here the situation is particularly
nice it's like a one parameter
instance on both axes
all instances look like yes yes yes yes
no no no no
and all algorithms look like buy right
try and try and print it by
or whatever buy it and then
in this case we figured out the optimal
solution
uh
for deterministic happiness
maybe we can do better using
randomization
so i haven't talked about randomized
algorithms okay you know
you might be wondering
you know what happens if the algorithm
is right
so just like in regret analysis you can
talk about
uh various powers that the adversary can
have so you can flip points now
your algorithms can flip coins
and you can ask how much
you know power does the adversary have
is the adversary adaptive or is it
oblivious
what do i mean does the algo does the
adversary get to see my coin tosses
you've seen this before should i say
more anybody
so okay so let me tell you what can be
done
if the adversary is adaptive if the
adversary can see my coin tosses before
giving the next request
then basically things are very bad
are general theorists due to bend the
weed and others
which say that pretty much
these kind of randomized algorithms are
not much more powerful than
deterministic
there's a slight gap out there so they
technically say if you can get
competitive ratio c using these kind of
algorithms you can get competitive ratio
c squared using deterministic characters
just in this gap and
you know we can talk about this
at some point it would be nice to
understand when exactly is this gap
really there
what's really going on
good so i mean coin toss is in the uh
okay what do i mean
you distinguish between those two here
for sure
yeah i think it doesn't really you know
either of these notions we are pretty
much dead
definitely coin tosses in the past but i
think coin toss is on this step as well
true so in this case uh you know you
can't really the request has to be
uh based only on a t minus one a one
through eighty minus
one then maybe you know i was i was just
getting confused
good
um
so we'll just work with oblivious
algorithms
what are oblivious where the adversary
doesn't get to see the coin tosses at
all
in this case what you can imagine is the
adversary fixes the input in advance
because it knows the algorithm it's not
going to see the coin tosses over time
so it might as well fix the input
and then the the only change that
happens is that i'm going to just put an
expectation
my algorithm is allowed to be randomized
and i can put an expectation
so this gives me a little more power
um
the expectations
everywhere that's relevant
by the way why should it give me power
for this problem
i just said the worst case input
is if the adversary you know stops the
request just after i buy
but if i'm randomizing the adversary
doesn't quite know when i buy
so it's exactly this randomness that
helps me
do better
so let's just do very quickly another
uh
example actually let me see how i'm
doing on time
so that uh
you know what instead of doing uh oh
let me just do it
so here is here is one possible
algorithm
i will i'm going to either buy on day b
over 2
or on day b
i'm going to buy on day b over 2 with
probability p and with 1 minus p i'm
going to buy only
okay
so now
really you know believe me
the instances that i care about are only
those which either stop on day b over
two
or on day
all other instances are not interesting
so on this instance how much do i pay
so the optimum is b over 2 of course i
should rent every time and how much do i
pay i pay p times
b over 2 plus b there's a minus 1
sitting there but ignore that
and then with 1 minus p probability i
was going to buy on day b so i'm going
to rank all the way so i'm going to play
b over 2.
so on this instance i'm going to
do the wrong thing
with probability p but to do the right
thing with probability 1 minus p
and on this instance
i'm going to
pay p times
v over 2 plus
b
plus 1 minus p times
actually i'm going to pay what am i
going to pay
on this instance i should just
[Music]
so i'm i'm buying on
day b over two
if i give you an instance of length b
over two
then with probability p
i'm going to buy on debut over two
and the probability 1 minus p i'm going
to rent all the way
until b
so should it be just p times p
plus 1
t plus 1 minus p times
divided by b so the two b is like two b
minus one but that would be let's ignore
the minus ones yeah
and now if you work this out you will
check you'll you'll see that uh if you
set p equals 0.4
then the
both these guys
are at most 1.8
so parts are good
but this is kind of giving you an idea
that look
sometimes you are doing the right thing
by flipping coins right
here you will you you accidentally did
the right thing by waiting
longer
and here you bought early even though
the sequence was wrong
you're heading between your backs
and this gives you an advantage
of course once you see this you should
say well maybe i should do better in
fact you should do better and you can do
better and let me just instead of
writing a lot more stuff let me quickly
show you what you can do
if i can get my computer to wake up
okay uh
let me move these guys over
okay
so
you guys see
so basically what i've written is i've
written down all the instances
and i've written down all the algorithms
remember algorithm a i buys on the ai
instance if i5 says yes for five days
and then you know
okay and i've i've
set the cost to be equal to four
and you can see what the competitive
ratios of various instances and
algorithms are
so for instance here you'll see 7 over 4
2 minus 1 over p
that's the largest number in this matrix
that's the worst case performance
now what you can do is you can say well
you know i should uh i should randomize
what's a randomized algorithm
the randomized algorithm is a
probability distribution over
deterministic outcomes
so i'm going to put down a probability
distribution over deterministic
algorithm and then try to analyze
well it's a complete pain to analyze
this because they're infinite by
infinite right i always get worried they
start whistling nervously but in this
case things are very nice
why
notice look at instance i five and look
at instance i infinity i infinity is by
the way a sequence which always says
which always asks you to you know this
season goes on forever you need to rent
all the way or buy at some point
you get i five nine
i infinity turn by term dominates high
five
you dominate i4 as well
the adversary has no incentive to give
i4
through here it should give i infinite
this is getting you know
this is a dominating strategy
it dominates all these things
so i'll never put any problem you know
the the the adversary will never give me
any of these instances it should just
keep being distanced
i'll get rid of those and let me see if
i can get rid of those
i'll get rid of i4 i5 and so on so
now
now what
given all this the algorithm says hey
you know the adversary is never going to
give me all these things i should get
rid of
these columns
these columns are strictly worse
than the previous column
so i'm just you know
iteratively getting rid of dominated
strategies
i'm left with a four by four matrix
that's my four by four matrix
i need to understand the game on this
4x4
and this game is very easy
do it in your sleep you know one thing
i'll do is one by one is the same as you
know whatever one by one is the same as
two by two etc i've just done this for
you know aesthetic beauty so that the
denominators are all the same
what am i going to do i need a
probability distribution over algebras
p1 should be
and then i want to say look what is the
best comparative ratio
i want to find a distribution
such that
any input
gives me compare ratio at most c
i need to do this and now here you'll
see the advantage i'm just showing you
some details
you're seeing the advantage of the
denominators all the same you can move
it to the right hand side
it looks like this and then you stare at
this lp and you realize oh this is a
very nice lp actually the optimal
solution is obtained by
equality at these constraints
and then you'll solve this lp
and here you'll get mass
and then you look at okay so what's the
answer the answer is some number like
this i don't know how to make sense okay
but what's the what's the algorithm so
the algorithm says with some probability
you're going to buy on day four
with three quarters that probability
you'll buy on day three
three quarters you'll buy on day two
with three quarters of that field by day
one
so the properties are increasing
exponentially
okay
and that gives you some competition and
then you think for a minute and you say
well actually you know that that four
out there
was really a b
you convince yourself that really the
answer is
that which is e max
so the limit the optimal
algorithm
is going to find these probabilities
which is going to give you compared
ratio of e over e minus one
uh there's some other there's a
continuous perspective on this but let's
not worry about that
you can actually just you know do some
integrals and get e over e minus one as
well but let's
okay uh oh maybe i should have said one
but before that did that make sense or
was that too fast
it's all good right you guys have seen
this
no you haven't but you understood it
good okay uh
so one more time
how do i show you over my e minus 1 is
optimal
so the way i do this is via the minimax
principle
in order to
so
what did i do
i i guess you guys can't see this
uh
everybody understands the competitive
ratio definition
in order to give a lower bound
over randomized algorithms
it suffices to give
distributions for which deterministic
algorithms can't do that
so what's what's what am i trying to do
i'm trying to
minimize
distributions
over algorithms
of the max
of instances
of the cost
of the algorithm on the instance
this i want to say
is at least
max distribution over
instances
when
uh over
algorithms
cost of the algorithm
this is like weak duality or the easy
direction of the mini maximum
it's also called
fundamental paper
so in order to show a lower bound what i
need to show is i need to show a
distribution over instances so that no
deterministic algorithm can do that
yeah um
are
hereby costing the
ratio
maybe
so in this case yeah uh
and how do you compute
this thing
it's just duality you put a distribution
over instances
the algorithms can't do that
so that lp that i wrote down
you write down the dual lp of that
what do i mean you know i'm just saying
i wrote down that instance and now i'm
going to say i'm going to give you a
distribution over instances
so that every algorithm
does poorly
or maximize that
and by strong duality for linear
programs those two will be the same
so in fact e over e minus one is the
right answer for this problem
because
then you're looking at the expectation
of the ratio and the expectation of the
uh
you're absolutely right
so i need to
do this no why
unless you love the table for the
so let me let me
think about this for a second
other questions
the denominator is deterministic in this
case
so the so problem that he's alluding to
is when i'm taking a distribution over
instances the denominator is changing
fix that problem
the competitive ratio is at the top
there the denominator is always the same
right sure
and so
but so you've written the game and so
it's it it's
just the competitive ratio doesn't show
up
but you don't need to have the same
development
let me
you know we will continue this
discussion later
i wish there was a
uh slack oh there is a slack but
uh you know i can you know clarify and
post something
yeah
um
showed us that the situation where you
uh like fix
what the worst case instance is and the
algorithm randomizes is equivalent to
lower bounded by setting where you fix
the algorithm
randomizer instances but we have looked
at settings where both the algorithm and
the instance are randomized good so uh
if you want to randomize over instances
you can actually choose the best case
instance out here so the maximum will be
achieved
so
there's no advantage to considering
there's no advantage once you fix this
distribution over uh algorithms things
there's no advantage to choosing
goods
so i don't have worse distribution it's
again an exponential but i'll have to uh
yeah
other questions
is this fact that
you're able to solve primal for optimal
randomized algorithm and take the tool
to get the lower bound
like more generally when you have finite
set of algorithms
it's
uh
so modulo this issue of
ratio of expectations and expectations
of ratios
it's you know it's basically for as long
as you can write uh your performance of
your algorithm is p transpose mq for
some matrix q then it's just zero sum
games
and uh that's all you're doing
and now i'm blanking on why you know
they live in this issue but it will come
to mind
and then it works out
okay
uh
thank you
uh what else anything else
okay i'm going slower than i should
uh
maybe a slightly higher level question
so
the first case
both the algorithm and the worst case
instance
you think there's some general
principle of that sort of
so the best answer i can give is maybe
because so another way of deriving these
same algorithms is via multiplicative
weights update algorithm and since
multiply debates update algorithm are
very related to you know uh
trying to maximize the entropy
given the sort of past
it's entirely possible to come up with
you know perhaps a general principle but
i don't know one
other questions
so let me talk a little bit about a
slightly different problem
um so by the way why did i uh spend this
time thinking about this because this
illustrates several issues that came in
the deterministic algorithms
will give you some performance and
randomization will often
help to get better
the randomized algorithms are really
distributions over deterministic
algorithms very often you won't be able
to write down this finite matrix because
these
these games are too large
but at least you can start thinking
about this
and then further the the fact that i
just erased that in order to give lower
bounds for determine for uh randomized
algorithms it suffices to give
distributions over inputs where every
deterministic algorithm performs fully
these are sort of general principles
that you'll use again again in designing
online algorithms
um
good
so the next
next problem that i want to talk about
is something that
uh
i'll call
what do i call it i call it
search
on a
uniform
metric
in the literature it often goes by the
name of cat and mouse game
so what's the what's the problem there
are n locations
they're all like you know imagine
they're all a distance one from each
other hence uniform metric
there's a mouse at some location
every day
the cat moves to some location
let's see
the mouse can see where the cat is the
cat doesn't see where the mouse is
if the cat moves to the mouse's location
the mouse has to move
so it moves somewhere
there the cat is there
i know
the mouse pays one every time it moves
i want to minimize the total cost
so the mouse can see the cat
so the mouse is the cat coming towards
it it scurries away
the cat can't see the most because
otherwise it's just true
uh so uh that you know the cat moves to
this location you can think of this as
the request
and then you know as the cat is there
you can imagine that the mouse is so
fast that the cat can't quite see it so
it just goes yeah
uh sure at some point but you know we
don't think about a sort of finite
horizon we just we can think about any
finite prefix of the sequence of
requests maybe the cat gets tired just
zips it
takes a nap
yeah because it's a uniform metric right
now
so in general you can talk about
problems where you're not in the uniform
metric and then the problem becomes you
know even more generally more
interesting but even this is you know
it's a it's a good problem to start off
with
any suggestions yeah
but in general yes
the graph is fixed
which is good
so the mouse goes to a random location
oh but the cat will eat it
oh but if the cat's on the mouse it
can't help but see
it's it's a small location
yeah so even though the cat doesn't see
the mouse this cat really understands
mice and knows this mouse's algorithm
yeah yeah so if our algorithm is to go
one two three four the cat will know to
follow us yeah
so the the algorithm should be kind of
known to both exactly
and this is part of this sort of
worst case you know opt
yeah
so for instance you might say oh move to
an arbitrary location
yeah if if i'm at location one
uh you know the the cat comes there i'm
the mouse i move to location two
you know arbitrary location and if the
mouse if the cat comes there i move back
to one
there are other locations
is this good
if the mouse moves to a place where the
cat already is
uh so you should always think of the
sort of cat as being you know midway in
the air and the mouse is scared
so the mouse doesn't have to move i
should have clarified that so if the cat
stays where it is
the mouse can stay with it
so so maybe all i'm saying is if the if
i'm in position one and the cat comes
there i'll move to two i think
there's n minus one valid locations to
move too there are n minus one valid
locations to move to the ones not
containing the cap just move to any of
them
so the problem is not escaping the chat
which the mouse can always do but doing
so doing so with low cost because
remember my cost is the total number of
moves
and i'm comparing myself to the opt
which is also minimizing total numbers
yeah
isn't it the case for any deterministic
strategy that you'd be forced to move a
return because
good so it could be the case that for
any deterministic strategy i'll be
forced to move every time
that's fine
the question is so here is here is a you
know
one strategy that i stay at one and
whenever the cat comes there i move to
two
and whenever uh
um
whenever the cat comes here i move back
to
one and maybe you know i i you know this
is my algorithm for
all pairs like this is this a good
strategy what does the optimal
offline optimal code so what would be an
input on which this strategy will pay a
lot but opt doesn't pay a lot
so so the cat just goes one two one two
one two one two one two
what's the optimal strategy for this
move to three
locked phase one
on this instance i pay infinity
is it clear
that's saying that the mouse
of my office
in this case the cat is adapting to the
algorithm of the mouse
so let me be clear here is one algorithm
i'm saying this algorithm is poor
i just want to
make sure that you agree so you
understand the algorithm right
the algorithm just says you know
wherever the edge goes you know that's
where you should move
and here is the instance
for the cat remember
the instance is specified by the cat the
mouse is the action that i'm taking
the instance says one two one two
so it doesn't mean that if uh chats if
mouse clicks on your strategy it doesn't
mean
exactly
exactly as raj says
what might happen
so what's happening in this thing is
that i'm just moving between one and two
but there's this very nice location
three that on this instance
is not visited by the cat at all
okay so one instance means
the path of the cat
thank you
other questions is the problem clear i
just want to make sure that the problem
is here
and do you see why this instance is bad
for this album
so in fact any algorithm that does not
visit all the locations
is is a terrible app
it has to be more than that
exactly
so here is an algorithm
that says so so let me give you an
algorithm it's called marking
mark
location
where cat is
mark any location where the cat has been
and whenever if
cat
comes to mouse
move
to unmarked
both ideas are good and then what
happens if all
locations
what
what does it mean that all locations
have been marked
the cat's been
everywhere what does this mean opt is at
least one
whatever strategy you take you must have
moved because the cat's been everywhere
right
so unmark
whenever you unmark everyone it's a
proof
that the cat's been everywhere
opt has paid at least one
how much could you have paid
in in this period between on markets
and
so you are uncompetitive
and you see you know even though
even though on both these algorithms the
the mouse pays at every single time
because it's a deterministic algorithm
some algorithms are still better than
others
okay so this is n competitive
and
this is n is the best you can do using
deterministic algorithms
that's a boring thing you know somehow
and i think of as large so this is not
very interesting when n is kind of large
but maybe randomization will happen
so
algorithm seems to be
a little bit more
powerful because
so what you're asking about is memory
less algorithms in some sense and memory
less algorithms i think
uh
so deterministic i'll have to think
about this for a second but randomize
algorithms for instance move to a random
location if n comparative
can i not think about this problem with
competitive ratio but try to just
minimize costs there's a key
like if i think of the game
that is unnormalized because here there
is no like quantity
i guess that i want to normalize was
compared to this
would that be a meaningful problem for
them
so you just want to minimize the cost
so i think i'm doing exactly that i'm
looking at my cost divided by the cost
of the adversary
i can have a count all right i start at
one i go to two every time i go around
try now so round robin is uh good round
robin is then competitive
and moving to a random location is also
in competitor
what's up what's a good randomizer
to a
random
unmarked location uniformly random
unmodification
great algorithm
and in fact that improves the
competitive ratio to login
why
so here's the here's the invariant you
can prove
and uh
so suppose these are all the locations
and there are some
art locations and there are other
unmarked locations
my invariant is
that the mouse is at a random unmarked
location
initially true
if the cat goes to a
you know if the mouse is sitting here
and the cat goes
and this portion gets marked then
conditioned on that i'm still at a
random unknown location uniformly random
unmarked
so what's the probability that the cat
will hit me
if there are n unmarked locations the
cat hits me with probably one over n
and then
then one location gets marked and the
cat hits me probably one over n minus
one
right
okay so so why is that easy to see
so let's do the following uh let's
imagine an instance so so the algorithm
she's asking the algorithm is i'll just
move to a random location
not a random mark no marking just a
random location every time the cat moves
there so let's just look at this
instance where the cat goes through
locations one through n minus one
and just keeps round robing over there
there is location n
but the mouse is not doing anything
smart
it's just flipping coins and trying to
find this sort of magic location
where the cat's not visiting
they'll take answers basic mouse should
move every time that the track is
exactly in the same location and that
happens in front one over and over
right
so
here's
you know but shuchi's question is an
excellent one which is that look
like what's happening here
so in my mind here's how i think about
this i think about let's look at this
period between things getting unmarked
so let's look at all the times
this is this is not the locations these
are times so this is p1
you know t t plus one etcetera these are
all types
at this point suppose everything got
unmarked
and then let's look at the next time
when the cat has visited all n locations
this is the first time when the cats
visited the nx location
since this point
this location has been just visited for
the first time
so magically if i knew this location i
should have just moved there
it's kind of furthest in the future in
some sense
what i'm doing is i'm searching for this
location
but i have no information but i have
some information over time as the cat
moves around
i'm doing search in this uniform metric
the way i'm doing this is either i can
flip a coin and just go to random
locations and search for this location
that's the other algorithm so that'll
take
n moves
or
what i can do is i can move to a random
location and you know in some sense i
move about halfway in the future
just randomly you know if i look at the
number of where the distinct locations
are
suppose you know this is distinct
location l1 this is distinct location l
now maybe this is l1 l2 l3
l4
these are the distinct end locations
this is the first time this location was
uh requested
so if i pick a random location i've gone
about halfway through
then i pick again i go halfway through
this gives me log
so related to the previous like on
deterministic so do you have any
algorithm with like less than m bits
storage
uh less than n-bit storage like is there
a trade-off between like the amount of
history i remember and
yes please so the reason we care about
these unmarked locations is because
we're trying to mimic the offline
optimal which has these like epics
almost where assuming the cat was going
to do what it's going to do anyway we
could just stay put at one location
so if i knew the entire instance what i
should have done is i should have gone
to this last location and then from
there i should have gone to the next
last location and so on and so forth
and what i'm doing is i'm just whittling
down the space of possibilities where
this last location
hence i'm searching for this magical
last location
so yes they do uh though so just marking
by itself you might you need a sort of
continuous version of marking and really
that leads naturally to the next kind of
things that i'll talk about so maybe
i'll come back to that in a moment
so uh
i'm out of time counting or can i say
one more thing
so let me just relate this back
to uh
to another problem uh actually
let me just say
a little generalization so what what did
i do
imagine the following thing
uh
i asked you so
to give me um
you know i'm i'll i'll rush this so you
know why don't i stop here
there's a half an hour break
and half an hour break we'll come back
and i'll tell you where this fits in
into this bigger picture and then we'll
talk a little more
is